foreign
starts this hour in Baltimore hi Shane
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up
all right so I feel like I know the
answer to this question which I hate but
I wanted to hear from you
um so I recently purchased a home from
my grandmother who passed and I knew it
was essentially a steal to buy because I
was going to get it way lower than it's
actually valued at so long story short I
have equity in the home which is awesome
but I've been struggling internally to
figure out if I should roll my credit
card debt into that home into the equity
of the home
and then pay that off with gazelle
intensity
um I have twenty six thousand dollars in
debt credit card debt and
I make 85 a year so you're single
I'm single what's the answer to your
question you know it
I know what it is I just but it would
free up 400 a month for me if I were to
roll it but I it's funny I tell my mom
like my problem is not the debt my
problem is that I'm not disciplined
enough
to knock it out like why do I need to
consolidate it into my into my equity
so
and that answer is what Shane
uh that
I mean I feel like I'm getting to a
point where
I really the answer is that I shouldn't
do it I know I know exactly what I
should do I just I wanted to make sure
it was the right thing to do the thing
that scares me let's kind of back up for
a second okay 400 a month is not true
okay that's forty eight hundred dollars
a year you're not saving that on twenty
seven thousand dollars worth of debt in
interest the only way you're saving 400
a month is if you're going to be in debt
longer
gotcha which is absolutely not your goal
no it's not okay so you're just trying
to dumb this down to make it easy and
it's not going to get easy the you know
it this is Band-Aid fast off
versus Band-Aid slow off and your get
gangrene
true that gross
hey Shane and I are okay Rachel you
don't have to worry about it if you
don't want in it's okay so I'm like
Google Imaging
oh Shane okay so
here's the deal yeah get fired up and
lay it out lay out the math and go what
is it you make Again by the way
85 okay so 27. so you're by yourself you
don't have to talk anybody into this
you're how old
29 okay one year
you really think I can do it in one year
I'm positive you can do it one year
I knew you were going to say this and
here's the problem Shane you have no
life
for a whole year all you're going to do
is work and eat ramen noodles and pay
debt no going out no eating out no
vacation work work work work work work
and you're done in a year see this is
only about twenty three hundred dollars
a month
and you're done in one year
what is the debt the 26 I know it's
credit card debt but what was it just on
was it just life was it it's life over
about eight years so that's what's going
to be hard Shane is it's not like this
is just a car loan and you made one
purchase that puts you in this these are
multiple decisions you know what I mean
over life and you're and you're used to
living that kind of lifestyle of twenty
six thousand dollars above what you've
been making so it's gonna feel even more
sacrificial in a sense uh so just as as
a heads up here's the thing if you'll do
this it'll make you a multi-millionaire
and here's why it'll make you a
multi-millionaire here's why because it
the anytime you get ready to be chaotic
and sloppy and disorganized and slip
back into credit card debt you will
remember the year from hell and you will
not let yourself do it
dang but if you wander your butt just
kind of lollygagging along out of debt
you will wander back in
because you but if you have to pay a
price I mean if you got the the year
from hell in your Consciousness and you
go crap no I'm not buying that there's
no way I'm not going on a month without
a budget I remember where that put me
before Oh and you this is this is it's
settled in your brain it's settled in
your body it's settled in your spirit
and that's why I'm telling you to do it
it's not just because it gets you out of
debt and it's not just because it's
absolutely the highest probability you
will win but what we're doing here is
we're resetting the way you handle money
for the rest of your life yep
and that's going to make you it's going
to make you're only 27 come back can we
not gonna make it 10 million dollars I
mean lit I promise you the math says it
because you know how to make money and
you've not been horrible with money I
mean you're not like as bad as like
Congress or something I mean you're not
you know you're not you're not ridic you
only got twenty seven thousand dollars
but it's just sloppy it's like the the
enemy pretty it's pretty intense not
isn't that the shame shame but like
twenty six thousand dollars in credit
card debt from just life though like
it's gonna be a shift chain like you got
to hear that but it needs to happen it
wasn't like this explosion of stupidity
it was gradual
you know like you said that's that's the
truth and and so the the danger of that
is is the enemy of Excellence is not
horrible the enemy of Excellence is okay
complacency yep it's oh this is good
enough
you know and we used to say this redneck
saying I don't know if they say this
kind of stuff anymore close enough for
government work have you ever heard that
one close enough for government work
nope which means half butt do your job
okay that's what it means in the
neighborhood I grew up in and so you
know it's mediocrity yeah you know and
so and and
you know Shane you're fighting what all
of America is fighting this slip into
mediocrity and you've got the ability
here to completely change that and the
cool thing is you already knew every bit
of it before you called here it now all
you got to do is go do it I'm proud of
you man proud of you great shame I can't
wait to do your debt free scream with
you in a year when you hate the Old
Shane so bad that you will never go back
to him and you were breaking up with him
never going back with him and so we're
going to be organized diligent have
money budgeted for fun money budgeted
for luxuries and we're going to go
become very wealthy and outrageously
generous and that's in your future you
could be a millionaire in 10 years
you really can be from where you're
sitting right now you're in really
because mainly because of headspace your
head space is excellent as long as the
gangrene doesn't get them
rip that Band-Aid off Shane
so gross